Alex risk is the CEO of pro-hospitality
group which is a group of 10 hotel
properties and it's valued around 100
million dollars
his newest hotel is called the Lexi
hotel which is Vegas's newest hotel it's
off the strip on Sahara Avenue and it is
being billed as the city's first
cannabis friendly hotel
[Music]
Lexi's interesting because it's the only
hotel right now that is allowing people
to smoke marijuana on some of the floors
adult use cannabis is legal in Nevada
but casinos are federally regulated and
on the federal level cannabis is still a
schedule one substance still completely
banned so there can be no marijuana use
that's condoned by any casino hotel in
the city what's interesting about the
Lexi is that it's not a casino hotel
it's just a boutique hotel it's rather
small with 64 rooms but the Lexi has
come out and said we have a fourth floor
we put air filtration systems there and
that's where
guests can smoke or consume cannabis in
a town like Las Vegas people kind of
assume you know it's known as Sin City
it assumes there's no rules it's
actually a highly regulated City there's
a lot of rules and even these casinos
they're very strict right now there are
no consumption lounges that are licensed
and operating in the city so as a
tourist you can go to the many
dispensaries but there's no place to
consume so what risk did is he decided
he would open this hotel and kind of put
himself out there in a gray area
admittedly and say we're gonna allow
paying guests to smoke in their hotel
rooms so when you look at it from that
angle it's interesting it's you know
he's kind of has a very measured Cowboy
mentality where his hotel isn't licensed
for any cannabis activity at all and he
just owns the property and deciding this
is what he wants to do
what we're trying to be is really
cannabis inclusive which is not kind of
eccentric and we are a fun boutique
hotel that is focused on well-being and
cannabis is part of it at the moment the
laws don't allow us to have public
consumption whether it be in the lounge
by the pool the restaurants or whatnot
so what we are able to do at the moment
is allowing consumption of cannabis in
your the privacy of your own room the
student can be very famous for floor is
where we allow the conception of
cannabis into the privacy of your own
rooms we try to find a little bit with
it so all of our fourth floor rooms are
420 and are numbered 420 a b c and so
forth risk came on my radar because the
Artisan hotel which is what the Lexi was
before Renovations was kind of this old
kind of funky eclectic Hotel it's
actually known at the the last part of
its life as a place you could party
could rent it for seventy three hundred
dollars all 64 rooms and it became known
in the local scene as kind of a hotel
that would host sex parties it sold for
12 million dollars and the guy who
bought it was Alex risk I've never heard
of him before he runs an outfit called
pro-hospitality group they raise some
money by these Standalone hotels and
then bring them new life so when someone
I didn't know bought a hotel in Vegas I
decided to find out and risk has a
really fascinating background
I'm originally from Montreal Canada I
used to be a military officer up in
Canada for eight years plus and I moved
to Phoenix 17 years ago and then two
years ago after after covid we were
trying to really try to find a way
specifically for one of the hotels we
own in downtown Phoenix the Clarendon
Hotel which is a historical Boutique
really funky hotel in Phoenix we were
trying to spruce up ourselves and go
back to pre-covered performances and in
November 2020
recreational Cannabis became legal in
Arizona
and we were approached by groups that
wanted to do campus friendly events so
we hired attorneys we met with the
cities we tried to making sure that what
we could put together was actually legal
we did we navigated those legal
structures and we found out that it was
a niche that was in the man and it was
something that people wanted they have a
members only Lounge
where you could bring your own pot and
you can smoke you can Vape you can
embite however you want then they have
these rooftop parties which are private
events they do THC infused dinners that
took off and it started doing well so we
decided to do it with a second property
so risk looked at the map and saw that
the Artisan hotel in Vegas was up for
sale and he bought it for 12 million
dollars they put a couple million in for
renovation so he's like all in for 15
million and he is kind of the only game
in town when it comes to a place being
cannabis friendly in Vegas
in Arizona a property owner can allow or
prohibit cannabis consumption so he's
like squarely in the law the law is very
well defined and they navigate that very
well in Las Vegas they can't do that
they can't allow smoking in a lounge
because it's considered public and the
kind of gray area is like what happens
in your room is that a private residence
the law in Nevada is actually quite gray
it's a it's it's kind of up for a debate
and I'm talking to the Cannabis
Regulators they say it's out of their
jurisdiction because they only deal with
licensed cannabis facilities he's not a
licensed cannabis facility so it's just
an interesting story about a
entrepreneur kind of going out on a limb
the next thing to look out for at the
Lexi and with risk is how the hotel
evolves you know he wants it to become
more like his Arizona property where
there's a members only smoking Lounge
right now you can't do that at his
property and the only way he could is if
state law is changed so risk said that's
his next step you know he's got the
hotel open now they're going to be about
85 percent capacity for the foreseeable
future which is great for a new property
especially off the strip and now he
wants to kind of take the concept A
little further and we will see what
happens at the state law level
the laws of recreational Cannabis are
very very young so those law
evolved or they will evolve and our goal
is to be at the Forefront of of these
laws we're trying to work with our
attorneys and and some lobbying firm in
order to try to approach the authorities
and try to change certain of those
definitions not only for us but for the
whole industry in general and try to see
if we can meet them in the middle and
try to make it a win-win for everyone
[Music]